MICHAEL WARD: His
stories are like nets
in which you catch for a moment
something ineffable, something
almost incommunicable.
But he has communicated it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
C.S. LEWIS: In Greek, there are
four words for love: storge...
MICHAEL WARD: C.S.
Lewis was just
a master of language he knew
how to point beyond words.
C.S. LEWIS: The eros
is much harder . . .
MICHAEL WARD: The
great thing about Lewis
was that he was creative
and imaginative,
as well as being highly
intellectual and analytical.
He is so skillful at
expressing the inexpressible.
What you'll get in this
course is an insight
into how Lewis understood
Christianity and wrote
about it, both in his
nonfiction and his fiction.
He knows what it is like to
have been an atheist, been
an unbeliever, been
a skeptic, and he
knows what it's like
to have come to faith.
Lewis had thought his
way into all corners
of the Christian faith--
pain, joy, love, miracles,
prayer, heaven, hell.
We're going to cover the
whole gamut of experience.
That's the great thing
about Lewis's presentation
of the faith.
He makes it live, he makes
it sing, he makes it move,
he gives it color.
That, I think, is
one of the things
that people so love about Lewis.
They feel like they're
not just reading books,
they're reading life, and
life with a capital L.
LARRY P. ARNN: C.S. Lewis
explained to the world
in beautiful English, in common
sense language why Christianity
is both good and plausible.
MICHAEL WARD: When you
come to Lewis's writings,
it's like you've
touched a live wire.
You've suddenly got
an electric shock
because here's someone who
really believes it and manages
to communicate how
much it means to him.
I'm Michael Ward.
This is "C.S. Lewis
on Christianity."
Let's begin!